ايله الماسك يخططه لطرح ميزه جديده في
تويتر ستنافس واتساب الميزات العديده التي
يرغب مالك تويتر جديد في اضافتها الى
المنصه كما اهمها التشفير التامه للرسائل
المباشره وذلك وفقا لموقع الذفارج ماسك
يريد ان يجعل من المستحيل على المتسللين
الوصول الى الرسائل المباشره لمستخدم
تويتر حتى في اسوء الظروف فقال انه يهدف
الى تمكين المستخدمين من التواصل دون
القلق على خصوصياتهم او اختراق بياناتهم
على تويتر انتشار الرسائلهم على شبكه
الانترنت فلن يكون هناك اي تجسس في تويتر
على رسائلهم الخاصه بالرغم من انه حدث عده
مرات مقابل ميزه تشفير هذه تتضمن الا يقرا
او يطلع اي طرف ثالث على الرسائل او
المكالمات حتى لو كان الشركه نفسها وهي
ميزه لا تتوفر الا عند واتساب